I realized that I wanted to be an
architect when I was seven years old
that Christmas my parents got me a
present but I will never forget hey guys
my name is Danny and in this video I
want to share with you my top three gift
ideas for architects and I'll also tell
you about the best present that I ever
received so for me the criteria for a
gift is really simple
number one usefulness is it something
that I can actually use everyday or is
it something that's just gonna sit there
and collect dust in my apartment most
architects I think are minimalist and
they're extremely organized so they hate
clutter and they hate having things that
are not essential to their lives
number two beauty isn't nice to look at
it's a nice touch is it gonna make you
happy when you see it the last criteria
is meaning what is the meaning behind
the object you're giving if you give
someone bath salt
it could mean I want you to have a
really nice relaxing evening or it can
mean so the first gift category is
notebooks or more skins
a notebook is an essential tool for an
architect and he or she is gonna go
through many of them throughout their
lifetime a good moleskin is high-quality
it's durable and it's much more
beautiful than a standard notebook it's
meaningful because it's something they
can use to develop their creativity and
they'll probably think of you every time
they use it
the tricky thing about notebooks is that
some people can be kind of particular
about it for sometimes for reasons that
you might not even understand out of all
of these can you
which one for gifts personally I like
black notebooks I like having a shelf
full of black notebook it just adds a
little bit of consistency
to my very inconsistent line in fact
this notebook has much better quality
paper than any of the other ones but I
just like having a shelf full of black
notebooks also it took me a couple of
years to figure out which ones I like
the best I used to have these big giant
notebooks without any lines on them but
I found that I was only using a small
portion of the pages then I started
using these tiny little notebooks
because they fit perfectly in my purse
and then I tried horizontal notebooks I
also experimented between blank
notebooks to grid and notebooks and now
I only used on of notebooks I don't
really buy any other notebooks
I like the dot @e fives I like having
the guidance but I find the cards to be
a little bit too bridgid I will put the
links to these in the bottom another
good gift idea is books architecture
books are generally beautifully designed
but are very expensive
here are some classics that every
architecture student will need these
King books I use them even out of school
when I was studying for my licensing
exams and I still use them today as a
reference but keep in mind technical
books are very high in the usefulness
factor but they might not have that wow
factor so if you want to go a slightly
different route inspirational books can
also be a great gift and last but not
least my personal favorite gift category
is a good pen or pencil and today I will
be talking specifically about the
rotring pens wrote rings are like the
Cadillac
it's the pen that you will use and
treasure your entire life it's German
but it's manufactured in Japan so you
know it's really good quality you can
tell it's a road shrink because they all
had red bands on them
the first rotring gift that I got was
from my girlfriends when I was leaving
for architecture school ten years ago
and they came to see me off at the
airport and they gave me this pen and
they said something about using this pen
to do great work the gift was a Road
train 600 pen and it has a full metal
body with the distinct rotring hexagonal
shape and this is the road train six
hundred and leva which means that it has
a speckled finish instead of the
straight black metal they actually don't
make this model anymore unfortunately
but they have the newer versions of the
fountain pens that you can buy and I've
tried them and they're just as good they
just the only difference is that they
have a knurled grip here this one
doesn't and I think this pen has
actually helped me become a better
sketcher and better note-taker
I just love writing with this pen it
just the ink flows so smoothly onto the
pages and it's just a very nice
satisfying writing experience they have
the weights that you just don't have on
a regular pen or pencil you know I kind
of feel like I'm holding a very
significant object of hands it's not
just
it's a tool that you use to bring your
ideas to life the weight of it also
helps you press down onto the pages
without putting too much pressure on it
and it also helps with the balance of
the pen so you can actually write for
longer periods of time
all the rotring full metal body pens or
pencils have this really nice weight to
them which I love and that being said I
would actually love to show you how it
actually writes but unfortunately I
dropped it right on the nib not too long
ago so it doesn't really work anymore
and because it's a special model I
haven't been able to find anyone to
replace it so that's the caveat if the
person you're getting this for is quite
clumsy then this might not be the best
skin for them and so they do have the
newer versions of these that come with
the knurled script here
oh also if you're getting them a
fountain pen make sure to check it has
the refillable cartridge if you get them
the cartridge and the bottle of ink with
the pen and that will make a really fine
gift
so the second rotring that I got was
from my mom a couple of years ago and
this one is the roaring 800 mechanical
pencil and like the fountain pen it is
full metal body so it has a very nice
weight to it and the weight keeps the
pen balanced when you're writing for
long periods of time and if you're
buying this for someone who's getting
to go to architecture school trust me
they will be drawing and writing for
long periods of time so the knurled grip
can be quite handy so I really love this
pencil it's beautifully detailed and it
also has a retractable tip so for
someone like me who likes to carry
around their pens and AFER's or in their
pockets this is a really good safety
feature the hexagonal shape also keeps
it from sliding off tilted tables and I
also found that compared to other
mechanical pencils it's much harder to
break the led on these I bought this
roadtrain 600 for myself because I
thought I had lost the other one and
it's a little bit more affordable than
the 800 but it doesn't have the
retractable tip it's also a slightly
smaller in diameter I I like them both I
think I actually prefer the size of the
600 a little bit more probably because I
have a pretty small hand but I think the
majority of people that I've spoken to
you actually prefer it I mean both of
these full metal ones are extremely high
quality and they'll last you a lifetime
they're in the thirty to forty dollar
range so it's a good price rate gift but
if you are looking for something more
affordable or you're maybe thinking of
getting it for yourself they also have
the 300 to 500 series which is which has
a classic body so it's much lighter but
it's also still very good quality
personally I think any of these like
full metal body pens
what makes really great is it kind of
takes all the boxes it's functional it's
durable and I'm pretty sure the person
you're getting this for will use it
almost every day it's just a really nice
object to have sitting on your desk it's
also very meaningful architects draw and
take notes all the time so this makes
that process much more pleasant the
mechanical pencils are probably a little
bit more practical than the fountain
pens but the fountain pens I think make
a much more memorable gift another last
idea is Copic pins so architects use
these all the time but they can also be
quite pricey you can buy the full set or
you can buy them in a set of five so you
can collect your inventory over time and
if you're getting it as a gift and if
you're getting one of the smaller sets I
would suggest getting some of the
neutral colors like the grays or the
beiges or the oranges because those are
the colors that we tend to use the most
you know just the fact that you've
watched until the end of this video
tells me that you really care about this
person and I'm pretty sure they're gonna
be happy with whatever you get them just
don't get them with your book so if you
found this video helpful please like and
subscribe and I'll see you in the next
video